even before the launch of Star Wars
Battlefront to Electronic Arts found
itself under scrutiny for its handling
of microtransactions and the loot crate
system in the game but now that it's
available in stores Battlefront 2 has
continued to receive widespread
attention and numerous reactionary
updates from EA to break down exactly
what happened from the October beta to
the current developments here are the
key elements explaining the controversy
behind Star Wars Battlefront 2 as the
sequel to 2015's battlefront which is
criticized for lacking a single-player
story and repetitive multiplayer
offerings battlefront 2 features new
modes and revisions to gameplay
including a single-player campaign
originally developer Dai stated that
battlefront 2 would receive free content
updates instead of a season pass that
players would periodically have to buy
into and part of those free updates were
new story missions maps and hero
characters
scheduled to release the same week the
last Jedi hits theaters
despite the newly added story mode
battlefront twos primary focus is its
online multiplayer here players can
advance in rank and acquire resources
for their classes and favorite
characters returning from the previous
battlefront is the star card system
which offers class and hero focused
amplifiers that increased stats and
grant new abilities for progression in
online modes greatly expanded in
battlefront 2 it's now a required part
of long term player growth star cards
are the most valuable tool you have to
customise and augment your characters
adding increases to damage health
regeneration along with alternate
loadouts
and skills each star card comes in four
tiers of quality common uncommon rare
and epic with increasing stats for
higher ranks
moreover amassing star cards for a
particular class will increase its level
opening up better crafting options for
higher tiered cards while most
multiplayer games feature systems that
tasks the player with investing time in
a particular class or set of equipment
Battlefront 2 mixes elements of steep
progression with randomized rewards from
dedicated crates these randomized yields
include additional star cards weapons
cosmetics and other resources the star
cards in particular are vital for
increasing the level of
character and with the dependence on the
games randomized yield for players to
acquire the bulk of their resources this
makes both grinding and chance a
necessary aspect of the battlefront to
experience leading up to battlefront
two's open beta the increased focus on
the game-changing star cards led to a
lot of concerns from fans and scrutiny
for the game all of which were wrapped
up within the increasingly common
mechanic known as the loot box from the
6th of October to the 11th EA opened up
the game to feedback with access to an
early beta version of the multiplayer in
the beta players found the live boxes
which yield randomized materials and
star cards for classes and hero
characters were one of the main pillars
of player advancement a common complaint
voiced by those that played the beta was
that the progression system felt
designed to encourage players to
purchase crates with real money to
advance more quickly EA's beta for
battlefront 2 would ultimately be a
turning point with a game in the public
eye in battlefront 2 star cards are in
large abundance compared to the 2015
game and some cards offer simple yet
incredibly effective upgrades one of the
larger criticisms from the beta was that
the epic level star cards and weapons
could be acquired from loot crate's
making it possible to reach high-level
status early on by buying loot crate's
or in other words pay to win after the
pita the developers took steps to alter
aspects of the game based on player
feedback EA published a blog post about
the state of the game citing player
feedback the developers adjusted areas
of the progression system in addition to
increasing the rate at which credits are
earned by a small amount the biggest
change EA applied to the game was
removing epic level rewards from crates
stating that it was done to help keep
everyone on a level playing field
the developers transitioned epics to the
in-game crafting system which is
currently the only way aside from
pre-order and deluxe edition bonuses to
acquire the highest tier star cards
still concerns about player progression
being dependent on the randomized
element of loot boxes remained
on November 10th EA released a trial
version of Star Wars Battlefront 2 on
Xbox one and PC for members of EA access
where the ten hour time limit users
could experience the first three levels
of the campaign and the full multiplayer
experience and all progress could carry
over into the final game upon release
this was the first opportunity for many
to dive into the final game which the
developers said they would always evolve
with player feedback upon further play
however some fans felt that the core
mechanics of the game weren't
effectively explained leading many to
feel frustration with the restrictions
and requirements of the game's economy
on the Star Wars Battlefront to read at
page a user voiced frustration after
taking advantage of one of the micro
transaction options unbeknownst to the
player the crystals could not be used to
purchase the various hero characters
which are only available to buy in the
form of credits this user wanted to
purchase the Darth Vader hero who at the
time cost sixty thousand credits within
the same thread and EA spokesperson
responded to the post stating the
following the intent is to provide
players with a sense of pride and
accomplishment for unlocking different
heroes as for cost we selected initial
values based upon data from the open
beta and other adjustments made to
milestone rewards before launch among
other things we're looking at average
per player credit earn rates on a daily
basis and we'll be making constant
adjustments to ensure that players have
challenges that are compelling rewarding
and of course attainable via gameplay
this comment was inundated with negative
reactions from fans soon becoming the
most disliked comment in reddit's
history with over 675 thousand down
votes following the backlash from the
post
the developers reduced prices for all
hero characters by 75% however they also
lowered the completion reward for the
campaign from 20,000 credits to just
5,000 this was done to match the altered
price to unlock the campaign hero
iDEN versio
on November 13th press reviews from
gaming outlets went live while many of
the initial reviews stated that the core
gameplay of battlefront 2 was fun and
exciting and it offered a diverse array
of content to go through the multiplayer
progression system was met with
widespread criticism with the game's
dependent on loot crate's many claimed
that the gameplay loop of battlefront 2
just didn't value play a time or
investment in the game after the reviews
were out and more players began to dive
into the game battlefront 2 found itself
under greater scrutiny from the
community and press alike eventually
even mainstream press sites such as CNN
and The Huffington Post began to cover
the game's focus on microtransactions
and loot crate's this increased
attention along with consumer complaints
led to the Belgian Gaming Commission
launching an investigation into
battlefront 2 and overwatch for possible
gambling practices EA released a
statement to GameSpot strongly denying
such connections to gambling creating a
fair and fun game experience is of
critical importance to EA
the crate mechanics of star wars
battlefront 2 are not gambling a
player's ability to succeed in the game
is not dependent on purchasing crates
players can also earn crates through
playing the game and not spending any
money at all once obtained players are
always guaranteed to receive content
that can be used in game prior to
battlefront twos official launch
crystals were exclusively used to
purchase loot crate's for additional
rewards circumventing the need for
credits while crystals can be acquired
from certain challenges and milestones
the most immediate way to attain them
was from the in-game store the purchase
options during early access and prior to
launch ranged from $4.99 for 500
crystals to $99.99 for 12,000 crystals
this also opened up possibilities for
players to take advantage of the premium
options to obtain a larger quantity of
star cards and resources over others
which fed back into player progression
but in the days since the beta and even
before its launch general perception to
how battlefront 2 offered these paid
options were unfavorable despite this
dice developers expressed that these
options were not paid to win and the
player progress would come down to play
a skill dice associate design director
dead
Brownville said you should not ever be
much made together with players who are
much better than you are ultimately your
effectiveness is going to come down to
skill not the star cards you have
in light of accusations of gambling and
overwhelming toxicity surrounding the
game eh CFO Blake Jorgensen made
comments about the state of the game
during a talk at the UBS global
technology conference on November 16th
in addition to commenting on the game he
stated that people need to be patient as
they looked for alternatives to address
the community's concerns so things that
we've heard today will tune into the
game and they'll be different tomorrow
running a live service is all about
constantly watching and listening to and
reacting to the community to try and
develop great gameplay but also players
should really understand that we listen
to the community very closely and we
will always be changing the games to
make those games better and make the
community more excited about playing
those games doing a reddit AMA leading
up to the game's launch dice developers
Dennis Brown Val and Paul Caslon spoke
about the backlash toward the game and
expressed that they were incredibly
saddened by the overall response Brandt
valve wrote we've made a really cool fun
and beautiful game but it was
overshadowed by issues with the
progression system we will fix this
[Music]
hours after the reddit AMA with dice
developers and shortly before the game's
official launch players suddenly found
that microtransactions were pulled from
the game without a proceeding
announcement when selecting the get more
crystals option from the loot crate menu
players will come to a blank screen
where the option to buy crystal packs
once was crystals are still obtainable
in-game via milestones and challenges
but they require a large time investment
to acquire soon after EA released a
statement announcing that all micro
transactions would be pulled from the
game until further notice we hear you
loud and clear so we're turning off all
in-game purchases we will now spend more
time listening adjusting and balancing
and tuning this means that the option to
purchase crystals in the game is now
offline and all progression will be
earned through gameplay the ability to
purchase crystals in-game will become
available at a later date only after
we've made changes to the game we'll
share more details as we work through
this as of the time of this video
battlefront 2 is fully playable in all
gameplay modes without micro transaction
options develop a Dyson publisher ea are
currently working on a new system and
while crystals are no longer available
to buy in packs at this time the
developers have stated that the currency
will return after adjustments have been
made whether the in-game purchases will
remain the same or will be modified to
offer different rewards remains to be
seen with its next batch of content
coming next month in time for the last
Jedi and with more content coming in the
months ahead
the developers plan to support the game
for the long term but along with new
modes and content EA and dice are now
tasked with coming up with a new
progression system be sure to check back
with GameSpot for all future updates
coming from the developers regarding the
state of battlefront to
[Music]